thank you very much for joining us a top
Ukrainian security advisor has warned
Russia's decision to station tactical
nuclear weapons in neighboring Belarus
will destabilize the country the
Ukrainian government says Moscow is
holding Belarus nuclear hostage
the comments come after President
Vladimir Putin said he'd reached an
agreement with the Belarusian President
Alexander lukashenko
I think who is right he said listen
where are your closest allies why do the
Americans deployed nuclear weapons at
their allies on their territory trained
the crews Pilots how to use this type of
weapon if needed we agreed that we'll do
the same without violating our
obligations I emphasize without
violating our International obligations
on the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons last week President Putin warned
Russia would be forced to react if the
UK supplies Ukraine with armor-piercing
rounds containing depleted uranium he
says Russia has stockpiles of similar
Weaponry but has stopped short of using
it meanwhile Ukraine's operation nuclear
power plant remains at risk it's come
under repeated shelling during the war
the U.N nuclear Watchdog Chief is
expected to assess the damage later this
week
well let's now speak to Susie Snyder
who's Program Coordinator at the
international campaign to abolish
nuclear weapons she's joining us live
from Utrecht in the Netherlands Susie
thank you very much for being with us on
Al Jazeera President Putin says this
move this plan would not violate nuclear
non-proliferation agreements and
compared it to to the U.S stationing its
weapons in Europe what is your reaction
first to this announcement by Russia and
what are the implications of Russia
storing tactical nuclear weapons in
Belarus
this movement is additionally
destabilizing it increases the risk of
the use of nuclear weapons by adding
more actors who might potentially have
the ability to drop nuclear bombs it
create a potential for for chaos and
miscommunication and that's a risky
scenario at the best of times in a time
of conflict it's extremely destabilizing
and very dangerous but he said Susie
that Russia would retain control of the
weapons but it would be indeed the first
time since the mid-1990s that Moscow
will have bases nuclear bases nuclear
arms rather outside the country what
more can you tell us first about the
Russian nuclear Arsenal its capabilities
and the risk that they could be used
well the capabilities of these weapons
they're often called tactical weapons
but that does not mean they are not
catastrophic these weapons are if used
would be would have results similar or
greater than what we saw in hiroshva and
Nagasaki in 1945. they are hugely
um they can cause huge catastrophic harm
and there is no recovery from any health
care system that could deal with that
type of catastrophe it doesn't matter
this the size of the weapon the
long-term consequences are also
something that we just don't have the
capacity to cope with so it's highly
problematic yeah but the American Susie
also have a nuclear weapons stored in
Europe it's estimated that there are a
hundred U.S owned nuclear weapons stored
in five NATO member states across six
bases in Belgium Germany and Italy
is this a violation also of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty
well this is this is one of the
questions under debate the um the
non-proliferation treaty does not
explicitly say you cannot store weapons
in another country but the pilots in
those countries are trained to use those
weapons and that would require a
transfer of control and that is
prohibited under the non-proliferation
treaty in addition this type of behavior
including the hosting of another
country's nuclear weapons is explicitly
forbidden under the Treaty of the
prohibition of nuclear weapons which
entered into force in January 2021. now
the UK meanwhile is sending depleted
uranium Munitions to Ukraine
not a bomb but is that also risky
any type of Munitions is extremely risky
and
um some have found that the depleted
uranium Munitions they do have a legacy
of harm there's been a lot of different
studies and conflicting results in terms
of what the Legacy and how bad that that
harm is
um but there's it's still a very
difficult situation and not one in which
um and which we should we should be in
one in which the precautionary
principles should win out and when
there's a risk of long-term
um
long-term harm that is not
distinguishable between civilian and
combatants that is one where we should
basically take a step back and
reconsider other options whenever
possible all right Susie so the
Americans we've heard their reaction
they're somewhat downplaying this
Russian plan to store uh these nuclear
weapons in Belarus
but should they be taken and should we
all be taking this more seriously how
concerned should we be and what should
be the next step the International
Community takes if this goes out
countries should really condemn this
announcement spreading nuclear weapons
into another country's territory is
always going to be problematic and the
U.S that does have nuclear weapons
stationed in five European countries
should reconsider that plan and take
those weapons home they're already
supposed to be moved back for for being
retrofitted and there are new weapons
that are meant to be deployed in the
coming year the new weapons don't need
to come in these weapons can stay back
in the U.S the US can say what it can do
what it says as well as you know being a
better example
um and all all countries need to
take seriously any and every threat to
to use or to further spread nuclear
technology because that is dangerous for
everyone regardless of where they are
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you for your time Susie Snyder is
from the international campaign to
abolish nuclear weapons joining us there
from the Netherlands sinks
thank you